monsieur le Président donc on va on a
prévu de vous faire un petit exposé
introductif là et bien sûr surtout de de
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
souhaiterez nous poser donc comme vous
l'avez mentionné donc depuis l'été on a
mis en place une gouvernance collégiale
au sein du GIP donc avec Julien Colette
qui est le directeur général on vous
fera cette présentation un peu à demain
alors quelques généralités sur sur la
Coupe du monde alors effectivement la
Coupe du monde de rugby c'est le
troisième grand événement sportif alors
on parle beaucoup de la même mentionné
des Jeux Olympiques auront lieu en 2024
mais on est très fier de dire la Coupe
du monde de rugby après les Jeux
Olympiques et la coupe du monde de foot
c'est l'événement le grand événement
sportif le plus important donc dans le
monde alors le rugby
c'est un sport qui a le vent le vent en
poupe aujourd'hui c'est un sport qui est
en pleine essor
avec une un sport qui était anglo-saxon
à l'origine mais maintenant qui se
généralise un peu dans tous les pays à
128 pays qui pratique ce beau sport un
sport qui se féminise aujourd'hui
l'augmentation des licenciés en
particulier en France il vient de
l'apport des défis et des jeunes femmes
qui qui découvrent ce sport qui peut
être aussi un sport féminin et puis donc
il y a plus de 800 millions de fans qui
suivent de te téléspectateurs qui
suivent les matchs de rugby dans le
monde alors on a fait une enquête
également sur sur la France avec auprès
d'un panel de spectateurs de femmes et
les gens apprécient le rugby 80% des
Français sont favorables à
l'organisation d'une coupe du monde de
rugby donc c'est important les les
Français soutiennent l'événement parce
qu'il considère à hauteur de 90% que cet
événement aura des retombées positives
pour pour le pays et en plus qui nous a
effectivement étonné c'est que les trois
quarts des Français souhaitent
participer à l'événement donc soit en
étant dans les stades soit en suivant
les compétitions derrière devant leur
écran
alors ensuite
on a la chance d'avoir une équipe de
France effectivement qui est assez
brillante en ce moment et pour nous le
le
l'objectif majeur d'une Coupe du Monde
c'est vraiment de faire une grande fête
alors on a pris un terme plus plus
générique que celui-là qui est le terme
de célébration mais c'est vraiment sous
ce mot là que l'on veut organiser
l'événement c'est une grande fête
populaire qui va se dérouler pendant 51
jours et qui va être dans tous les
territoires de France et donc on espère
qu'on pourra effectivement construire
des grands moments d'événements sportifs
alors la compétition
au niveau du plateau sportif va être
exceptionnel puisqu'on va avoir les les
20 meilleures équipes de rugby dans le
monde qui seront qui vont s'affronter
pendant 51 jours donc c'est c'est 660
joueurs soit 660 joueurs qui seront
réunis 20 nations qualifiées et on pense
qu'on aura un plateau sportif tout à
fait exceptionnel parce qu'en fait les
cartes
les cartes ont été vraiment rebattues
aujourd'hui au niveau du rugby mondial
le premier pays c'est l'Irlande et on a
bien sûr les grands pays du Sud
l'Australie la Nouvelle-Zélande
l'Afrique du Sud mais il y a des
nouveaux pays qui émergent dans le monde
du rugby comme la Géorgie comme pour la
première fois le Chili qui va participer
à sa première à sa première Coupe du
Monde il y aura trois pays du d'Amérique
du Sud qui seront présents avec le Chili
l'Argentine et l'Uruguay donc un sport
qui se un plateau sportif qui va être
tout à fait exceptionnel alors le
calendrier
pour ceux qui ne le connaissent pas donc
il y a d'abord des matchs de poules il y
a quatre poules qui réunissent cinq
équipes alors la particularité d'une
coupe du monde de rugby c'est que c'est
pas un événement parisien pour pour
happy few c'est vraiment un événement
qui se déroulera dans dans neuf stades
dans les grandes villes de province donc
il y a d'abord les les cinq les quatre
matchs de poules et ensuite il y a des
quarts de finale des demi-finales et la
finale et ainsi que la petite finale de
bronze qui aura lieu au Stade de France
alors la fête la célébration pourquoi
c'est parce qu'effectivement le
l'événement il va être complètement
national encore une fois les les stades
je les citerai tout à l'heure mais c'est
les grandes villes de France et donc on
considère qu'à peu près alors à part
l'est de la France Alsace la Lorraine la
Bourgogne et la frange comté mais on
peut considérer qu'aujourd'hui 80% de la
population française sera à moins de
deux heures d'un site de compétition
alors il y aura les 9 les les neuf
stades où se déroulant les compétitions
mais il y a également les camps de base
donc il y a 20 camp de base plus les
bases camp de match va essayer de match
donc en fait c'est une cinquantaine de
villes qui auront le plaisir
d'accueillir également les équipes
pendant entre entre les matchs donc 10
vélos je l'ai mentionné et neuf neuf
stade haute
alors les stades vous les avez en sur le
slide suivant donc la compétition ça
démarre le 8 septembre jusqu'au 28
octobre donc c'est une compétition qui
est longue ça dure pratiquement deux
mois 10 vélos de 51 jours de fête et
donc vous avez ici et donc on l'a de
façon plus détaillée après voilà les
différents stades qui vont accueillir
les compétitions donc on aura Lille
Saint-Denis alors Paris on considère que
c'était également une ville haute parce
qu'il y aura des des
le centre de presse le broadcast etc qui
seront basés à Paris ensuite il y a
Nantes Bordeaux Toulouse Marseille Nice
Saint-Étienne et Lyon
[Musique]
voilà
après j'étais passé la parole maintenant
à Julien pour détailler les d'autres
sujets
monsieur le pasidan mesdames Messieurs
les rapporteur mesdames sénatrice
monsieur les sénateurs très heureux de
venir rapporter de vous au sujet de
l'organisation de cette Coupe du Monde
président me donne l'occasion
après ce slide sur les les stades les
neuf stades qui vont accueillir la
compétition peut-être de faire un
éclairage sur l'économie de l'événement
puisque le président Laffont nous
attendu cette perche en introduction
Les et c'est venu sur la table
effectivement lors du changement de
gouvernance nous sortons d'une revue
budgétaire complète qui a montré que
lorsque l'on compare le niveau de
dépenses d'exploitation nécessaire
l'organisation de cet événement au
standard internationaux hier nous sommes
en train d'organiser le président aigual
le rappelait le troisième événement
sportif mondial avec près d'un milliard
de téléspectateurs qui sera alors
peu importe la répétition des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques ou pas la
répétition peu importe mais en tout cas
qui sera sous les lumières du monde
entier on ne peut pas le faire à un
niveau de dépenses inférieur à celui de
nos prédécesseurs sauf à considérer que
les Japonais et les Anglais étaient
absolument incompétents en matière
d'organisation d'événements ce qui n'est
évidemment pas le cas or le niveau de
dépenses moyen pour l'organisation des
précédentes Coupe du monde étaient
autour de 250 millions d'euros il était
prévu avant la revue budgétaire un
niveau de dépenses inférieur à 200
millions d'euros qui mettaient en danger
qui mettait en risque le niveau de
qualité d'organisation de l'événement
donc il était notre responsabilité en
relation extrêmement étroite avec l'État
et avec World rugby ainsi qu'avec la
Fédération française de rugby de revoir
ce niveau de dépenses non seulement pour
prendre en compte l'effet inflationniste
que vous connaissez tous qui impacte
l'ensemble
des métiers qui sont aussi les nôtres
mais aussi simplement
on viendra plus tard sur la partie
recette mais parmi et ça fera la
transition avec le reste de cette
présentation parmi les dépenses qui sont
importantes et qui avait été en partie
sous-estimé par choix par choix de
considérer que l'État et les
collectivités locales elle est assurée
des dépenses qui leur incombaient pas
forcément en termes de sécurité nous
avons
évidemment travailler de manière étroite
avec notre directeur de la sécurité qui
est à ma droite Olivier d'un prêt avec
les services de l'État avec la CNJ avec
le ministère de l'intérieur avec les
digestes et les dix Jobs à revoir les
dispositifs de sécurité et assurer lors
conformité à la fois nos obligations et
aussi leur adeptabilité au contexte
locaux à la situation de chaque stade et
à la situation de chaque camp de base
le second élément c'est que pour assurer
la meilleure sécurité de cet événement
il faut intégrer la sécurité à la
qualité des parcours clients et des
parcours spectateurs et non pas la
considérer comme
une politique à part vivant sa vie en
dehors de l'organisation d'événements la
clé c'est que tout au long du parcours
spectateur c'est-à-dire du départ d'un
tenteur de billets depuis l'aéroport de
sa ville de sa ville de résidence à
l'autre bout du monde dans l'hémisphère
sud ou depuis Londres en Eurostar qu'il
puisse sentir que la sécurité
est assurée de la meilleure manière
notamment par le fait qu'on puisse
communiquer avec lui de manière très
étroite et de ce point de vue là le
choix stratégique qui a été fait dès le
départ de maîtriser l'ensemble du
processus de commercialisation et de
gestion de la billetterie par un système
qui nous permet
de détenir les données de tous nos
clients de tous nos détenteurs de
billets et donc de pouvoir communiquer
avec eux puisque ces clients
naturellement qui nous laisse l'usage de
leur donner puisqu'il considère
quand ils achète un billet ils font un
achat loisirs ils font un achat plaisir
et donc ils ont confiance dans la
personne qui organise l'événement il
n'achète pas un réfrigérateur à qui est
avec la réticence à donner des des leurs
données à un opérateur industriel qu'il
ne connaissent pas donc cette force qui
nous permet d'exploiter les données
clients d'un million de personnes nous
permet aussi de communiquer avec eux et
de les intégrer finalement à notre
dispositif de de sécurisation
les dispositifs comme je le disais vont
être adaptés à chaque contexte local
dans le cadre de d'études de sûreté
notamment liés à chaque camp de base au
vin camp de base on y reviendra
aujourd'hui pour nous il est de
finaliser la possession des contrats de
démarches et de sécurité privée dans le
cadre de marchés publics puisque nous
sommes soumis naturellement droit de la
commande publique nous devons déployer
6300 agents de sécurité privée sur les 9
sites de compétition un peu au-delà si
on compte les camps de base
à part deux ou trois sites un peu en
tension mais qui ne nous inquiète pas
outre mesure il faut savoir
que le pic de mobilisation d'agents de
sécurité privée sur un week-end
organisation de la Coupe du Monde
correspond à un week-end de match de
Ligue 1
donc le marché de la sécurité privée
aujourd'hui en France est en mesure de
répondre à nos besoins à la fois en
qualité et en quantité d'agents sachant
encore une fois que la compétition a
lieu pendant l'automne qu'elle n'a pas
lieu en plein cœur de l'été et qu'elle
est répartie sur 9 sites différentes
compétitions d'ici au total avec la
Ville de Paris qui accueille des
fonctions essentielles à l'organisation
d'événements donc on a pas besoin de
concentrer comme ça peut être le cas des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
concentrer
un nombre extrêmement important d'agents
de sécurité sur une sur une seule région
pendant une période estivale
pour le reste le point clé en matière de
sécurité c'est la coordination avec les
acteurs et non seulement avec les
acteurs avec les forces de sécurité
intérieure naturellement et dans ce
cadre là nous nous fonctionnons
sous l'aide d'un partenariat avec le
ministère de l'intérieur d'une
convention de partenariat avec le
ministère d'intérieur mais aussi avec
les autres acteurs concernés qui sont
les opérateurs de transport en
particulier et les collectivités locales
les autorités organisatrices et
transports au niveau des collectivités
des métropoles et ce point est clé pour
la gestion des flux et la fluidité de la
gestion des flux autour des stades en
amont des matchs et après les matchs
nous reviendrons bien évidemment sur les
questions de sécurité si vous le
souhaitez plus tard une priorité de
l'organisation de l'événement pour la
Fédération internationale de rugby pour
avoir le rugby qui explique aussi la
durée de l'événement les 51 jours
qui qui sont mobilisés pour organiser
les 48 matchs c'est la santé des joueurs
la santé des joueurs le respect de la
santé des joueurs exige 5 jours de repos
pour toutes les équipes durant la
compétition
ce qui nous a amenés à prolonger
en fait à intensifier le nombre de jours
de repos de manière significative par
rapport aux précédentes éditions de la
Coupe du monde puisque comme vous le
voyez que ce soit en Angleterre au Pays
de Galles en 2015 ou au Japon en 2019 le
nombre de jours de repos était inférieur
à 340 et il va être
supérieur d'une centaine pour l'édition
de notre coupe du monde avec 33 joueurs
mobilisés pour chaque équipe au lieu de
31 dans au cours des éditions
précédentes en matière de revenus la
commercialisation de la billetterie à
rencontrer un succès qu'on peut
qualifier de phénoménales c'est-à-dire
que les billets se sont ils vont passer
l'expression se sont vraiment arrachés
comme des petits pains
aujourd'hui les 2,2 millions de billets
réservés réservé au grand public sont
tous vendus nous avons mis en ligne au
mois de au mois de janvier une
plateforme officielle de revente de la
billetterie qui est le seul canal par
lequel
légalement les détenteurs de billets
peuvent
revendre leurs billets et ceux au prix
facial d'achat plus l'application d'une
d'une participation frais de 10% du prix
facial d'achat
sachant que nous développons en
parallèle une politique de lutte contre
le marché noir en particulier de
surveillance des plateformes comme
viagogo avec laquais contre laquelle
nous venons d'obtenir une décision de
justice d'ailleurs favorable mais aussi
contre toutes les plateformes
internet qui autoriserait des détenteurs
de billets à essayer de revendre leur
billet à des prix supérieurs au prix au
prix facial et en tout cas de manière
par un autre canal que la plateforme
officielle de revente
la billetterie c'est la principale
source de nos revenus nous avons encore
une fois à peu près 400 millions d'euros
à couvrir de dépenses les 218 millions
d'euros de dépenses exploitation dont je
parlais et puis le reste est en
constitué des droits que nous achetons à
worldog be pour organiser la Coupe du
monde
et
la billetterie représente au terme de
notre dernière revue budgétaire 347
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
donc c'est la clé
évidemment c'est la clé de la création
de valeur dans l'organisation de cette
Coupe du monde à la fois en termes de
revenus et aussi en termes
d'expérience spectateurs et
d'enrichissement de cette expérience
spectateur
comme je le disais le fait que nous
maîtrisions cette billetterie nous
permet de connaître parfaitement le
public qui a acheté des billets et comme
vous le voyez sur
sur cette diapositive mais bien entendu
nous diffuserons cette présentation nous
pouvons nous connaissons parfaitement la
répartition des acheteurs par genre
alors il se trouve que le public rugby
reste très masculin mais comme le disait
Jacques rivol en introduction il y a de
plus en plus de jeunes femmes qui
pratiquent le rugby donc
la féminisation est en cours est
accélérée mais ça reste un public très
masculin en revanche et ça c'est plutôt
une bonne surprise pour nous
contrairement à l'audience des matchs du
des matchs du 15 de France que les
diffuseurs nous donnent qui est
âgé
qui est en moyenne dans la majorité
constituée d'hommes âgés de plus de 40
ans nous avons aujourd'hui une majorité
comme vous le voyez une majorité de
détenteurs de billets qui ont moins de
40 ans ce qui est plutôt extrêmement
positif et une très bonne nouvelle à
tout point de vue à la fois pour le
renouvellement du public et aussi bien
entendu pour en matière de de
participation de ce public à la vie de
l'événement et plus généralement à
l'animation du territoire
nous connaissons naturellement la
provenance des acheteurs de billets
comme vous le voyez comme vous le voyez
sur cette diète positive
la répartie
heureusement plus de la moitié des
spectateurs sont français donc on peut
penser que les stades vont vibrer au son
de la au son de la Marseillaise de
manière très forte et c'est important
mais les Anglais les Irlandais les
Britanniques en général ont acheté
beaucoup de billets ils sont évidemment
très fans de rugby comme vous le savez
l'Angleterre est quand même le berceau
de ce sport dont on va fêter d'ailleurs
le bicentenaire cette année
et donc ce sont parmi les 40%
d'acheteurs de billets qui viennent de
l'étranger
60% viennent des îles britanniques le
reste se répartissant de manière
c'est marginale mais entre beaucoup de
pays dont des pays bien entendu de
l'hémisphère sud
concernant la répartition géographique
des acheteurs français par région ou par
département d'ailleurs du territoire
de manière assez
peu surprenantes les Toulousains vont
venir en force dans les stades mais
aussi mais aussi les Parisiens les
Girondins et au-delà de ça ce qui est
intéressant de constater à la lecture de
ce graphique c'est que le rugby n'est
plus seulement un sport du Sud-Ouest et
de la région parisienne
mais rayonne bien au-delà
sénateur Savin constatera notamment que
l'Isère est bien placé mais pas
seulement puisque
puisque
de manière un peu plus surprenante la
loi Atlantique la loi Atlantique ou le
Nord sont également des portsvoyeurs de
fans de manière importante parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a des stades c'est
vrai qu'il y a des stades mais ça montre
qu'il y a des fans de l'équipe de France
de rugby et au delà dans ces
départements de manière forte donc
aujourd'hui ce sport est en plein essor
sur tout le territoire il faut le noter
avec une exception notable qui reste le
grand est une terre de mission pour le
rugby à tout point de vue bien merci
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
Président et Monsieur le Directeur
général du GIP mondial rugby pour cette
pour cette présentation
je commencerai par une question sur la
sécurité parce que malheureusement j'ai
envie de dire aujourd'hui on ne peut
plus parler de d'organisation de grands
événements sportifs international sans
évoquer cette question de la sécurité et
vous savez qu'on sort d'un débat ici
concernant le texte de jeux olympiques
et paralympique qui a été
essentiellement sécuritaire et avec des
dispositions qui vont d'abord concerner
la Coupe du monde de rugby
chronologiquement avant l'organisation
des Jeux Olympiques et
paralympique alors bien sûr on connaît
pas le texte définitif puisqu'il est
toujours pas passé à l'Assemblée
nationale mais j'aurais savoir quel est
le regard quelle est l'analyse que vous
faites d'ores et déjà du texte tel qu'il
est sorti de nos débats sénatoriaux tout
en sachant que derrière cette
problématique de la sécurité se pose
notamment la question de la relation
entre les organisateurs et puis les
supporters plus ou moins organisés bon
alors j'ai vu qu'il y avait notamment
des par exemple une amicale des
supporters du 15 de France une
association des supporters du XV de
France etc je voudrais savoir si ce type
de d'instance ce type de structuration
de supporters ont été associés à la
préparation de cet événement
deuxièmement bien évidemment
aujourd'hui je dis pas ce qui domine
parce qu'il faut surtout pas généraliser
mais le sport français quand même
traversé par tout un ensemble de crises
de gouvernance auquel le rugby n'a pas
échappé c'est vrai du côté de la
Fédération française de rugby parce que
c'est quand même rarissime c'est quand
même exceptionnel de voir en France un
président de fédération sportive
démissionné bon donc c'est tout à fait
rarissime et la Fédération représente
cela a été rappelé tout à l'heure les
deux tiers de l'actionnariat du GIP donc
nous bien sûr on vit ça de l'extérieur
mais on a du on est un petit peu de mal
à reprendre ce que ce qui a été dit tout
à l'heure c'est-à-dire que tu aurais eu
aucun impact sur la préparation de la
Coupe du monde de rugby de cette de
cette crise de gouvernance et puis en
lien avec ce que je viens de dire j'ai
vu dans votre organigramme vous avez un
comité d'éthique
et je voudrais savoir si effectivement
ce comité d'éthique a été associé s'est
réuni au cours de ces de ces derniers
mois au cours de ces dernières années
parce que je crois qu'on est un certain
nombre à souhaiter justement davantage
de responsabilité davantage de
prérogatives au sein de ces comités
d'éthique interne à tel ou tel
fédération ou à tel ou tel structure qui
organise des événements de cette
importance
alors par ailleurs une question sur
l'héritage parce qu'on parle beaucoup
d'héritage olympique mais je crois que
maintenant pour chaque grand événement
sportif on sera amené à parler de
l'héritage et je voudrais savoir que ce
que vous attendez en terme d'héritage
même si vous l'avez plus ou moins abordé
tout à l'heure ce que vous avez débuté
votre propos en disant que le
rugby se portait de mieux en mieux je
dirais sur le plan mondial c'est vrai
mais sur le plan national c'est pas tout
à fait vrai puisque il y a une baisse du
nombre de clubs et une baisse du nombre
de licenciés alors c'est vrai que le
covid est passé par là quoi
on peut discuter des chiffres
avec un redémarrage maintenant mais donc
qu'attendez-vous justement en termes
d'héritage est-ce que vous sentez une
véritable mobilisation des clubs quoi
derrière cette organisation et quand
j'ai d'héritage c'est notamment en
tenant compte de cette expérience qui
est qui a été celle de 2016 puisque la
France est déjà organisée la Coupe du
monde de rugby en 2007 et enfin une
dernière question bon vous avez évoqué
la dimension budgétaire je n'y reviens
que très très partiellement
je voudrais savoir parce que vous n'avez
pas mentionné mais ce qu'apporte
effectivement World rugby financièrement
ou alors est-ce que c'est simplement le
sponsoring qui transite je dirais par
World de rugby et est-ce que vous savez
comme ça une estimation à la louche
puisqu'on est ici au Sénat maison des
collectivités des territoires est-ce que
vous avez une estimation à vous de ce
que les collectivités globalement vont
apporter à cette organisation notamment
mais pas simplement à travers les camps
de base merci ok très bien ben des jeux
à rouler je vais donner aussi
monsieur le Président d'abord
remercier mais sur le président le
directeur général pour
l'exposé qui viennent de nous présenter
moi si je vais revenir sur deux points
qui aujourd'hui sont pour nous les plus
importants c'est bien sûr la sécurité
mais aussi l'habiller tri qui qui peut
aussi aujourd'hui nous interroger sur la
sécurité la première question elle est
un petit peu en lien avec celle qui
vient de poser Jean-Jacques Lauzac
la question c'est est-ce que avez-vous
l'intention de d'utiliser les moyens que
la loi olympique a été lors de son
dernier débat notamment sur
toutes les mesures qui sont liées à la
sécurité des personnes notamment la
vidéoprotection les caméras installées
sur les ronf sur les ainsi que les
véhicules et entre tout ce qui est aussi
la sécurité sur les véhicules et les
entreprises de transport public donc
quelles relations avez-vous parce que là
c'est pas un site c'est différente
villes qui sont concernées avec des
moyens de transport complètement
différents certains ont des métros
d'autres des transports par tram et
autres donc tout ça est-ce qu'il y a un
travail qui est fait spécifique par par
ville ou au niveau de la sécurité
deuxième point sur la sécurité
c'est ça concerne bien sûr vous avez
parlé des stades mais qu'en est-il des
camps de base mais aussi des fans zone
est-ce que les collectivités est-ce que
c'est à la charge de l'organisateur la
sécurité dans les fans mais aussi il y a
des lieux on sait qu'au niveau du rugby
il y a des lieux il y a la première et
deuxième mi-temps qui se passe sur le
stade et puis la troisième qui se passe
dans des lieux de rassemblement qui sont
bien identifiés dans certaines villes
est-ce qu'un travail est fait
spécifiquement en termes de sécurité au
lieu de ces autour de ces sites avec les
villes hautes troisièmement toujours sur
la sécurité
est-ce qu'il y a une partie qui est à la
charge des collectivités en termes de
sécurité notamment sur la sécurité
privée vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
vous n'irez pas normalement de problème
mais on sait que c'est quand même c'est
un métier qui est en tension les
sociétés de sécurité ont du mal à
recruter à former des personnels bon
c'est vrai que dans une période
peut-être plus propice et puis disperser
sur différents sites ce qui peut
permettre peut-être de pouvoir répondre
à votre appel d'offres donc où en est où
en est votre appel d'offres et comment
se situent cette organisation en termes
de sécurité
et puis sur notre maintenant sur la
billetterie parce que vous pouvez nous
présenter parce qu'il y a eu la première
vente qui a été faite avec les paquets
et puis le grand public aujourd'hui
a été mis en place sous votre
responsabilité vous allez confirmer la
plateforme de revente est-ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter cette plateforme
de revente avec
est-ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous avez mis en place une sécurité
contre la fraude et le marché noir des
billets qui peut être potentiellement
exil qui peut potentiellement exister
parce qu'on voit que le nombre de
billets a été très largement vendu et
donc quand il y a une grosse demande il
y a risque de fraude et de marcher noir
enfin
il avait été présenté au démarrage de
cette coupe du monde de rugby par la
Fédération Française de oui mais aussi
par les organisateurs de France 2023 que
certaines équipes même s'ils étaient
éliminés du premier tour restaurer en
France sur le territoire et
organiserait avec
les comités régionaux avec la Fédération
avec des collectivités des activités il
resterait la durée de la Coupe du monde
et que cette présence serait prise en
charge par la Fédération française de
rugby est-ce que c'est toujours
d'actualité est-ce que parce que ça a
été présenté et mis en avant lorsque les
communes les villes les métropoles ont
été candidates pour recevoir des campes
bases et c'est vrai le fait que de
recevoir certaines équipes et se dire
même si c'est une petite une équipe
entre guillemets de pas de première
ordre mais qui peut rester la durée du
tournoi ça va créer une dynamique autour
de du rugby est-ce que c'est toujours
d'actualité et c'est intéressant de
savoir où ces équipes resteront et enfin
dernier point monsieur le Président
toujours sur l'héritage est-ce bien la
Fédération Française du rugby qui va
gérer le montant de l'héritage et qui va
mettre en place des actions auprès du
rugby amateur ou est-ce que c'est France
2023 qui va gérer de son côté cet
héritage merci
monsieur le Président alors on va se
répartir les réponses avec aussi Julien
bien sûr et Olivier d'impres qui est
notre responsable de la sécurité comme
on avait bien imaginé que vous auriez eu
vous allez avoir des questions sur la
sécurité on s'est dit qu'on allait
l'amener voilà parce que c'est lui
l'expert du sujet alors peut-être sur
déjà sur la sur la gouvernance donc il y
a deux sujets sur la gouvernance et
effectivement les problèmes de
gouvernance de la Fédération Française
de Rugby et les problèmes de gouvernance
spécifiques au GIP vous l'aviez monsieur
le Président mentionné dans dans votre
introduction avec les événements de
l'été qui nous ont amenés à à remplacer
le directeur général précédent alors
donc sur la Fédération française de
rugby ce qu'il faut bien que les gens
comprennent parce que parfois c'est
c'est pas toujours très clair c'est
qu'en fait la préparation d'une coupe du
monde de rugby c'est la responsabilité
d'un comité d'organisation que je
préside dont le directeur général et
Julien Colette qui est une structure qui
a pris la forme juridique d'un GIP d'un
groupement d'un terrain public qui est
un comité finalement une structure
indépendante une entreprise en fait qui
prépare et qui travaillent pour préparer
cet événement
dans lequel il y a effectivement trois
membres fondateurs il y a le Comité
national olympique sportif français pour
1% et il y a surtout la Fédération
française de rugby pour 67 % des droits
de vote et l'État pour 32 % donc nos
deux actionnaires si on prend cette
image en fait principaux c'est l'état
d'un côté et la Fédération française de
rugby donc c'est vrai que il y a eu les
affaires que vous mentionnez depuis
l'été médiatico juridique sur la
gouvernance de la Fédération française
de rugby mais en fait qui sont des
problèmes connexes au comité
d'organisation et qui finalement n'ont
pas impacté le comité d'organisation
puisque nous on a continué à travailler
les décisions étaient prises les
instances ont fonctionné on a un conseil
d'administration on a des assemblées
générales on a des comités régaliens
dans lesquels sont représentés les
participes les représentants de la
Fédération Française de Rugby et ça ça a
continué finalement alors c'est vrai que
il y a eu un buzz un peu négatif sur le
rugby lié à ses affaires mais ça n'a pas
impacté la préparation de l'événement et
aujourd'hui moi je peux vous dire qu'on
est complètement complètement en
trajectoire on n'a pas pris de retard
tous nos indicateurs sont ouverts on l'a
dit la billetterie a été vendue les
sponsors sont là l'engouement on vous a
montré quelques chiffres du du public
français et là et finalement l'événement
est tellement fort que ces problèmes de
gouvernance comme le disait Julien n'ont
pas impacté l'événement parce que
l'événement est plus fort que que ce
buzz médiatique et finalement
aujourd'hui on avance et on n'a pas eu
de retard sur ces sujets là donc ça
c'était pour les problèmes de
gouvernance qui sont un peu connexes à
côté de nous qui sont ceux de la
Fédération française de rugby après on a
eu nos propres problèmes de gouvernance
alors là quelques quelques éléments
factuels l'histoire a démarré avec des
des articles de presse qui effectivement
ont souligné un management qui avait été
qualifié comme négatif pour ne pas
employer d'autres termes dans la foulée
de ces articles de presse la ministre
des Sports a immédiatement bien réagi en
diligent en deux choses
le premier c'est à saisir le comité
d'éthique du GIP donc ça c'est les
propres instances de gouvernance du GIP
qui ont fonctionné donc il y a eu un une
saisine par la ministre du comité
d'éthique et parallèlement il y a une
saisine de l'inspection du travail donc
il y a eu deux missions qui ont été
lancés la première donc le comité
d'éthique donc présidé par un hommage
distra en retraite qui est Alain pigeon
qui a présidé la Cour des comptes donc
c'est quelqu'un un personnage qui est
une crédibilité affirmée dans et qui
fait autorité sur ces sujets là donc il
a il a produit un rapport du comité
d'éthique qui nous a été remis
exactement le 19 août et à la lecture de
ce rapport parce qu'en fait on ne
voulait pas uniquement prendre des
décisions basées sur des articles de
presse on voulait avoir des approches
objectives de ce qui s'était passé donc
ce rapport de comité d'éthique a été
très très bien construit il y a eu 19
personnes il y a une centaine de
personnes dans le comité d'organisation
donc il a eu 19 personnes qui ont été
auditionnées et donc à confirmer en fait
les articles de presse donc à la lecture
de ce rapport qui ont confirmé des
pratiques managériales alarmantes et
donc qui mettaient en danger la sécurité
et la santé des salariés donc nous avons
pris nos responsabilités au sein du
conseil d'administration et donc on a
mis à pied le directeur général donc ça
c'était la première étape donc la mise à
pied du directeur général qui a été
effectué le 29 août et c'était une mise
à pied à titre conservatoire dans
l'attente du rapport définitif de
l'inspection du travail et que nous
avons eu début octobre et qui a conduit
là à la deuxième étape qui a consisté à
ce qu'on licencie le directeur général
alors comme c'était un contrat à durée
déterminée la la formule juridique a été
la rupture anticipée de son contrat de
travail en fait c'est un licenciement
pour faute grave justifié par ces deux
rapports celui du comité d'éthique et
celui de l'inspection du travail donc
c'est une approche tout à fait
rationnelle qui a été faite et je pense
que c'est c'est assez satisfaisant de
voir que ce sont les instances propres à
la gouvernance du GIP qui ont dans un
premier pour fonctionner au travers de
ce comité d'éthique puis après le
rapport de l'inspection du travail et
donc cette procédure a été tout à fait
conforme à la fois au droit du travail
et au droit également public puisque
nous sommes un groupement d'intérêt
public donc on a on a fait les choses
tout à fait dans l'ordre en toute
transparence et en toute en respect
parfait de la de la réglementation pour
produire donc cette décision qui a
consisté de façon unanime avec tous les
membres fondateurs il y avait la
Fédération française de rugby l'État et
bien sûr aussi ou en drugby qui a été
parti prenante dans le processus
décision donc qui nous a amenés à
apprendre cette décision de changement
de la gouvernance et en miroir donc moi
on m'a j'ai donc été amené à proposer un
plan d'action suite au départ du
directeur général et donc ce qui a été
proposé ce que j'ai proposé aux membres
fondateur c'est de mettre en place une
gouvernance collégiale donc avec un
président qui jusque là était un
président tout à fait non exécutif et
très peu impliqué sur la conduite du
dossier moi j'avais pas de bureau
j'étais pas présent régulièrement dans
les de fonctionnement donc d'un
président plus opérationnel plus plus
présent dans le pilotage du du comité
d'organisation un directeur général donc
qui est Julien Colette et une directrice
générale adjointe Martine nemessec qui
pilote plus particulièrement
l'organisation du tournoi donc
aujourd'hui on préside cette gouvernance
de façon collégiale transparente et on a
remobilisé en fait tous les tous les
acteurs toutes les parties prenantes
autour du projet et encore une fois on
n'a pas pris de retard et on a
complètement
mis en place tous les les éléments
nécessaires à l'organisation successful
de cet événement donc voilà ce que je
pouvais vous dire sur les sujets de
gouvernance peut-être un mot vous
l'aviez mentionné aussi dans votre
introduction sur le résultat économique
de l'événement
Julien mentionné les dépenses il a
mentionné également les recettes au
final aujourd'hui après avoir fait un
travail en profondeur de revue
budgétaire là qu'on vient présenter
notre conseil d'administration il y a 15
jours on est capable d'affirmer qu'on va
sortir le résultat économiques résultat
financiers de l'événement qui sera entre
45 et 50 millions donc c'est un chiffre
très très bon puisque déjà dans le monde
des grands événements sportifs c'est pas
toujours évident d'avoir des grands
événements sportifs qui sont positifs
nous on sera nettement positif entre 45
et 50 millions d'euros et on a si on
peut le resituer par rapport à d'autres
événements qu'on parle pour nous les
meilleurs références c'est la Coupe du
Monde qui avait eu en France en 2007 ou
celle qui avait eu lieu en Angleterre en
2015 et ces deux Coupe du monde ont
laissé autour de 36 munitions 36
millions d'euros de l'époque donc avec
un résultat autour de 45 à 50 millions
on peut dire qu'on aura une coupe du
monde qui sera très profitable et comme
vous le savez
ce résultat nous on a actionnaire qu'on
va rémunérer l'actionnaire qu'on
rémunère c'est le rugby français puisque
finalement le résultat et ensuite
redistribuer à l'euro près au
développement du sport en France donc
c'est le sujet de l'héritage que vous
avez passionné aussi et donc qui fera
l'objet effectivement de d'une politique
de redistribution de ces 45 à 50
millions à l'ensemble du rugby du rugby
français voilà
peut-être là je passerai la parole à
Julien pour vous expliquer c'est un
process assez complexe qu'on a mis en
place sur la manière de redistribuer
l'héritage à la famille de rugby la
Fédération la ligue nationale de rugby
mais aussi les collectivités les villes
et les métropoles hautes qui ont été
partis prenantes dans dans l'opération
peut-être Julien tu peux détailler ça
oui merci Jacques effectivement pour
commencer à répondre
sur l'héritage les premièrement il faut
dire que le
bénéfice exploitation des opérations
d'organisation du tournoi va être
supérieur à 60 millions d'euros les 45
entre 45 et 50 millions d'euros dont
parle Jacques rivaual sont le résultat
après prise en compte de campus 2023 de
l'économie de campus 2023 qui n'était
pas prévu par définition dans le dossier
de candidatures donc quand le dossier de
candidature affiché un résultat de 68
millions d'euros
évidemment sans anticiper les impacts de
l'inflation actuelle nous allons dégager
sur spérimètre là plus de 60 millions
d'euros donc cet événement va être très
profitable et effectivement comme le
prévoit la convention constitutive et
l'intention de départ des mondes
fondateurs la FFR et l'État la totalité
de de
l'héritage donc du de ce qu'on appelle
le bonus de liquidation du GIP mais ce
qui veut au bénéfice d'exploitation il y
a au à des actions de développement du
rugby sur tout le territoire et non pas
des frais de fonctionnement de la
Fédération française de rugby ou de la
Ligue nationale de rugby ou de jeunes
c'est qui uniquement des actions de
développement de rugby dans ces actions
de développement du rugby 9 millions
sont déjà fléchés vers des aides à
l'emploi pour pérenniser 250 emplois
d'apprentis sachant que l'Agence
nationale du sport va débloquer la même
somme pour
aidé à la pérennisation de 250 autres
emplois d'apprentis campus 2023 par
ailleurs autour d'une quinzaine de
millions d'euros doivent être selon des
modalités qui sont en cours de
définition avec les services de l'État
doivent être dédiés à l'aide au centre
de formation des clubs pro les
comme vous le savez les clubs pro ont
s'appuyant sur le réseau amateur et sur
la politique de formation de la
Fédération Française de Rugby
forme beaucoup de jeunes joueurs tous
les ans très talentueux qui constitue
une réserve pour le 15 de France qui
permet le succès du XV de France donc il
contribue à la performance du rugby
français de manière très forte
il permet à des jeunes à des jeunes
passionnés de rugby de de faire valoir
leur performances dans des centres de
formation tout en poursuivant des études
dans le cadre d'un projet d'un double
projet et donc dans ce cadre là il est
important qu'être au titre de l'héritage
un montant important soit soit porté en
soutien c'est de l'ordre de 15 millions
d'euros le solde va être réparti entre
les collectivités locales à hauteur de
30% de 30% du montant pour des projets
d'investissement en lien avec des clubs
amateurs ou des organes déconcentrés de
la fédération
et au-delà de ces au-delà de ces 30% des
aides vont aller directement au club
amateurs pour des projets
qu'ils sont capables de développer
eux-mêmes sachant que et vous n'êtes
évidemment pas sans l'ignorer les clubs
amateurs sont très rarement propriétaire
des infrastructures des équipements
voire des matériels et donc ce sont les
collectivités particulièrement les
communes ou les ou les EPCI qui
porteront la plupart du temps ces
projets et qui bénéficieront en premier
lieu de ces aides mais pour bénéficier
de ces aides aideront y associer
obligatoirement ou un club ou un organe
un comité départemental de rugby ou une
migrationnelle de rugby
un comité héritage est en cours de
constitution et rendre un avis sur
chaque projet et chaque projet fera
aussi l'objet d'un avis préalable du
comité d'éthique avant que le conseil
d'administration la prouve
terme de gouvernance aujourd'hui les
instances se réunissent tous les mois et
demi nous rendons compte voilà pouvoir
exécutif rencontre devant le Parlement
du gypse tous les mois et demi nous
avons parlementarisé le fonctionnement
du zip et nous nous en portons très bien
concernant
concernant le fait pour répondre aussi
au sénateur Savin le projet de faire
rester des équipes perdantes sur le
territoire jusqu'à la fin du tournoi
c'était une belle promesse
voilà nous mais qui n'avait pas été
malheureusement prise sans consulter ni
World rugby ni les fédérations
nationales et il se trouve que les
fédérations nationales dont sont
originaires ces équipes nous ont
expliqué que c'était quand même très
embêtant de garder en France des joueurs
qui devaient rejoindre des championnats
nationaux
au plus vite et donc nous nous n'avons
pas donné suite à cette proposition qui
par ailleurs n'était pas financée
concernant la billetterie
donc nous avons fait le choix
effectivement de créer une plateforme
officielle de revente qui est la seule
plateforme qui garantit aux détenteurs
de billets de pouvoir revendre leurs
billets
de manière
légale c'est à dire sans risque d'être
poursuivi pour cause de marché noir et
sans risque aussi d'acheter pour les
acheteurs d'acheter des billets qui
soient des des de vrais billets et pas
des billets manipulés ou des copies etc
etc cette plateforme de revente
elle n'autorise la revente qu'au prix
faciale de vendre du billet avec
l'application je l'ai dit d'une
participation au frais de l'ordre de 10%
donc ce qui n'évite pas le marché noir
puisqu'il y a la tentation de revendre
plus cher sur d'autres plateformes et
pour ça nous avons mis en place un
système de détection
de suivi des plateformes type diagogo
qui ont tendance à donner de la place au
marché noir et nous les poursuivons en
justice dès lors que nous détectons des
mouvements des transactions anormales et
nous avons obtenu très récemment une
décision de justice favorable contre
viagogo et nous le ferons contre
d'autres plateformes aux besoins
il faut souligner que de ce point de vue
la billetterie le fait qu'on maîtrise la
billetterie
est essentiel et ça fera le lien avec
aux questions portant sur la sécurité
pour
garantir des conditions optimales de
sécurité à l'événement sur deux plans le
premier c'est qu'on maîtrise les données
clients on l'a dit ça permet à la fois
de méditer que des billets électroniques
et donc de ne pas avoir
de problématiques de contrôle de billets
imprimés billets papier et ça permet
aussi de d'accroître la sécurité la
cybersécurité de l'événement qui
aujourd'hui la menace majeure qui pèse
en fait sur sur l'organisation de
l'événement
nous travaillons de manière très étroite
avec le centre de renseignements
olympique qui a attaché à les cnsj et
les fonctionnaires de police du centre
de renseignement olympique ont
identifié comme menace principale le
risque cyber plus que les risques
d'attentats d'attaque terroristes ou de
délinquance
donc ce risque là et vraiment parmi nos
priorités à traiter nous travaillons de
ce point de vue là de manière très
étroite avec l'ancie nous avons nous
faisons aussi appel à un prestataire
spécialisé pour identifier les failles
éventuelles de sécurité dans la gestion
de nos systèmes d'information
sachant que de ce point de vue là le
principal système d'information
qui mérite une attention particulière
c'est le système de contrôle des accès
au stade
catastrophe majeure ce serait que le
système ne contrôle d'accès au stade
c'est fondre au juste avant un match
majeur donc nous concentrons nos efforts
sur les sécurisation de ce système et ce
qui nous aide c'est de maîtriser le
système de billetterie en amont et de
pouvoir communiquer de manière très
étroite avec les détenteurs de billets
donc des audits sont pilotés par landeci
sur chacun de ces systèmes d'information
en particulier sur le contrôle d'accès
et
un
rattaché à notre centre principal des
opérations à l'état majeur du tournoi
pendant le tournoi sera créé un centre
des opérations de sécurité notamment un
centre des opérations de sécurité si de
cybersécurité
donc ça permettra de suivre de suivre
ces sujets là de manière permanente
envahie permanente et nous sommes en
veille permanente
sur cet aspect là en matière de sécurité
alors effectivement il y a des quelques
groupes de supporters organisés mais ce
n'est pas quand même la culture du rugby
a un contrairement à celle du foot
donc de ce point de vue là un nous avons
quand même des relations avec les
fédérations nationales en particulier
les fédérations des îles britanniques
qui
dont vont être originaires beaucoup de
fans donc pour connaître leurs habitudes
etc etc nous savons aussi par le biais
de sondage auprès des détenteurs de
billets puisque nous détenons leur
donner que ceux-ci vont passer plusieurs
jours en France généralement famille ou
entre amis avec un budget conséquent
pour passer du temps
dans le pays profité de sa gastronomie
de son patrimoine et etc donc on va pas
être dans une logique de déplacement de
supporters
cibler sur une période très courte
avec l'idée de de uniquement de
fréquenter une rue de la soif un soir et
de repartir sans avoir forcément dormi
dans un hôtel là on est
notre public est constituée de personnes
venant de l'étranger qui ont tous des
gens de l'hôtel qui ont un pouvoir
d'achat assez élevé qui ont prévu de
venir passer de séjourner en France de
manière assez durable donc ce qui nous
permet quand même de cibler les risques
de débordement avec le centre de
renseignements olympique de manière
assez fine et fiable et concernant le
public de supporters on est aussi
français on est aussi en lien évidemment
avec les clubs pro dans quasiment chaque
ville haute il y a des clubs pro de
rugby qui connaissent bien leur public
concernant la sécurité des villages de
rugby et des rue de la soif puisque je
crois que le sénateur Lauzac parlait de
ça
concernant la vraie où ça pardon c'est
notaire ça va pas pardon
la sécurisation
la sécurité
la sécurisation des zones de célébration
effectivement de la responsabilité des
collectivités locales mais en lien avec
les forces de sécurité antérieure et
avec notre soutien en termes de conseils
naturellement dans le cadre de de
coordination et de ce point de vue là
des comités de pilotage ont été mis en
place avec les préfectures dès le début
de l'année 2022 avec des groupes de
travail thématiques liés aux mobilité à
la sécurité des zones de célébration à
la sécurité des stades etc etc donc sur
chacun de ces sujets la coordination des
acteurs est très étroitement
assurés
ceci étant je pense que les
collectivités en l'occurrence sont un
débat avec l'État sur le coup de prise
en charge de la sécurité des Fan Zone et
le rôle des forces de sécurité
intérieure dans cette dans cette prise
en charge mais c'est assez c'est assez
classique et concernant
concernant les les les zones de
célébration autre un les préfets sont
très attentifs à ce que
les villages de rugby soit les zones
principales de célébration et que le
maximum de fans puissent se réunir dans
ces zones qui sont plus faciles et
sécuriser que des zones disséminées
et donc aujourd'hui et c'est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles sur le
territoire de la métropole européenne de
l'île on n'a pas encore de zone de
célébration
identifiées les préfets souhaitent
privilégier les zones de célébration
officielles ce qui n'interdit pas
évidemment aux fans de fréquenter de
fréquenter les bars les pubs etc etc et
les restaurants mais là en Ligue 1 avec
les organisations professionnelles
notamment lui
on essaie de coordonner avec les
préfectures des dispositifs de sécurité
qui permettent de cibler d'identifier
les zones
privilégiées de réunions
des fans de rugby voilà on les connaît à
Paris on les connaît ailleurs on les
connaît Toulouse etc etc donc elles sont
relativement bien
identifiées mais c'est vrai que là il
peut y avoir il peut y avoir un risque
peut-être pour terminer sur l'aspect
sécurité les appels d'offres sont en
cours la passation des appels d'offres
est en cours de finalisation vraiment
c'est une histoire de jour on a
identifié bien sûr quelques fragilités
mais pas inquiet en général parce
qu'encore une fois le nombre d'agents de
sécurité qu'on cherche et leur
déploiement sont assez
usuels sur le marché de la sécurité
privée en France ceci étant ont même si
il n'y a que 20% des détenteurs de
billets qui seront des femmes on a un
sujet de mobilisation d'agents femmes
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas encore sûr
d'avoir le nombre d'agents femmes
suffisant pour contrôler les 20% de
détentrices de billets mais on y
travaille avec la filière avec les
filières locales avec le soutien de
l'État et des préfectures et du CNAPS en
particulier et tes antennes locales
et puis on a on a identifié
deux villes surtout de deux métropoles
ou
parce qu'il y a des spécificités locales
on aura besoin de prolonger l'appel
d'offres de gré à gré parce que
par exemple le FC Nantes a constitué un
service de sécurité interne qui ne lui
permet pas de répondre à nos appels
d'offres et donc aujourd'hui on doit
passer par d'autres biais pour avoir
pour travailler avec les sociétés de
sécurité mais c'est vraiment lié à un
contexte local voilà en espérant en
avoir rien oublié monsieur le Président
si il y a juste un point sur la
participation de du World rugby
rugby ne participe pas financièrement
puisque c'est nous qui achetons des
droits à World drugby à hauteur
de 200 millions d'euros de droits
d'organisation enfin de 196 millions
d'euros exactement plus les droits
liés à l'organisation des prestations de
hospitalité
qui sont de l'ordre de 90 millions
d'euros donc nous contribuons au
financement de rugby mondial à hauteur
de 280 millions d'euros
qui est derrière vertueux puisque c'est
280 millions d'euros vont principalement
aux fédérations en développement et non
pas aux fédérations déjà professionnelle
premièrement
deuxièmement seul World rugby ce finance
avec 5 sponsors mais pas avec les autres
les autres sponsors nous financent nous
directement au tort de 80 millions
d'euros et enfin les collectivités
locales nous finance directement à
hauteur de 20 000 d'une vingtaine de
millions d'euros donc sur les 200
millions d'euros de dépenses
d'organisation strictes or les droits et
sur les
les 340 millions d'euros de recettes 440
millions de recettes pardon donc c'est
c'est un montant
assez modeste mais qui ne prend pas en
compte la mise à disposition
d'installation notamment des camps de
base et des stades donc il y a un effort
plus élevé en réalité donc le soutien
des collectivités locales est important
et c'est pour ça que nous travaillons
avec elle de manière étroite sur
l'héritage pour qu'elle bénéficie
directement de retour en termes
d'héritage notamment bénéfice des clubs
qui sont sur leur territoire merci allez
je vais prendre toutes vos questions on
vous demandant d'être assez synthétique
et en commençant par le supporter de
Brive pierre ouzouillas
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président je
dois vous le dire que j'ai été
particulièrement intéressé par votre
allocution parce que pour moi le rubis
c'est pas seulement un sport c'est un
art de vivre c'est une philosophie de la
vie donc vous nous parlez de célébration
pour moi c'est une cérémonie quasi
culturelle qu'il faut le réorganiser bon
je repasse en mode parisien monsieur le
Président vous m'excuserez pour pour
célébrer
rugby je voudrais dire que c'est aussi
l'esprit du Sénat parce qu'ici nous
avons des affrontements parfois un peu
vif mais non respectons les règles et
l'arbitre
ne respectons l'adversaire et nous avons
des 3e mi-temps donc il y a il y a
quelque chose de proche entre l'esprit
rugby et l'esprit du Sénat moi je vous
l'ai surtout vous féliciter parce que
vous avez
raffuté les assauts de mes collègues
mais moi je voulais vous vraiment vous
féliciter et très sincèrement
d'avoir mis cette composition cette
cette compétition sous l'esprit général
de la fraternité parce qu'un événement
sportif c'est d'abord ça c'est la
rencontre sur le terrain la rencontre à
l'extérieur du terrain de personnes qui
ont des cultures différentes mais qui
partagent un même enthousiasme et je
pense que c'est vraiment très fort de
d'avoir un système je suis aussi très
content de de cette idée d'avoir mis en
place le rugby festival donc qui permet
de sortir du carcan un petit peu étroit
de l'organisation
très très
réglementé pour permettre une
participation plus large et très
sincèrement il faudrait que
vous mettiez à contribution les élus
pour que chacun dans leur territoire je
suis prêt à le faire dans les dans les
Hauts-de-Seine vous aide à initier
auprès des collectivités une une
relation qui permet justement de faire
vivre voilà alors je dis ça alors que
Brive va affronter la racine samedi que
ça va sans doute pas très bien se passer
merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur les présidents et directeurs
générales pour la présentation et les
réponses aux nombreuses questions qui
ont déjà été posées moi je voulais juste
peut-être revenir puisque je préside la
délégation droit des femmes au Sénat va
revenir sur un joueur sur quatre
finalement qui est une femme et je
voulais d'abord savoir si cette
statistique était le fruit d'un travail
des instances du rugby et comment vous
expliquer également que finalement cette
cette montée en puissance des femmes
dans le sport du rugby ne se retrouvait
pas au niveau des spectateurs est-ce que
vous aviez au niveau de la billetterie
une politique finalement d'ouvrir sans
avoir la volonté finalement d'avoir des
offres qui s'adresseraient peut-être
plus à des familles plus à des femmes
est-ce que c'était ce résultat là
ensuite j'avais une question également
sur le modèle économique est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si ce modèle économique
que vous nous avez présenté
qui repose essentiellement sur la
billetterie finalement est le même
modèle économique dans tous les grands
événements sportifs et puisque j'imagine
que non et voilà le voisin d'en face
souffle la réponse donc peut-être qu'il
pourra y répondre à votre place monsieur
le Président
et puis j'avais des questions sur
éventuellement on a vu il y a neuf sites
est-ce qu'il y a un ratio par rapport à
un nombre de d'événements pour les
matchs pour les sites pour les
spectateurs au niveau d'un équilibre
financier c'est-à-dire que vous avez
choisi 9 sites est-ce que c'est le
modèle économique qui fonctionne ou
est-ce que au-delà c'était en termes
d'équilibre financier c'était plus
compliqué à gérer et j'ai pu constater
dans votre présentation que sur les
sites il y avait une jauge qui était
très différente c'est à dire qu'on varie
quasiment du simple au double donc
est-ce que la sécurité demande
en fait multiplié par deux lorsqu'on
parle du simple au double ou multiplié
par 3 comment vous gérez cette sécurité
sur des sites extrêmement différents et
également les capacités de transport
puisque nous sommes évidemment
lorsque vous êtes à Paris où vous êtes à
Nantes les capacités sont sont
différentes moi j'ai noté aussi que la
Bretagne était très absente de
du public c'est pas une carte de rugby
au cas mais bon Nantes Nantes finalement
vous avez cité Nantes et la
Loire-Atlantique donc est-ce que vous
n'expliquez pas l'absence aussi par
l'absence de site sur lequel il va y
avoir des compétitions est-ce qu'il y a
un lien entre compétition et et
participation du public et puis
peut-être une question un peu plus
impertinente sur la slide qui faisait
référence au jour de repos puisque en
2015 il y avait 331 jours de repos en
2023 il y en aura 441
dans une période où on évoque beaucoup
le travail actuellement ben écoutez quid
les joueurs sont-ils fatigués en 2023
oui merci monsieur le Président je ne
vais pas me forcer à prendre l'accent du
Sud-Ouest tout seul
président de ce directeur pour pour
répondre très très précise et pour les
informations que vous avez données sur
l'organisation de la Coupe du monde de
rugby je dirais à mes collègues que ça
fait grand plaisir que l'on parle de
rugby parce qu'il y a dans cette
commission sorte de lobby de du football
qui nous a
imposé pendant des mois et des mois de
ne parler que de ballon rond donc merci
de nous permettre de parler un petit peu
de ballon de ballon au Val ce matin
mon intervention je vous le dis tout de
suite ne signifie aucune nostalgie de
rubis cassoulet ni des 3e mi-temps ni de
la gestion de l'époque des parties
dessus de la Fédération française mais
mais malgré tout un peu je regardais
votre tableau tout à l'heure je suis élu
du premier département au nombre
d'achats de billets qui n'apprite pas
une métropole
et c'est un peu mes collègues opposé des
questions très techniques la mienne sera
peut-être un peu plus de l'ordre de du
politique sur la politique de
déploiement et de développement du rugby
dans notre pays cependant parmi toutes
les questions techniques qui ont été
posées par notre rapporteur et par le
président du groupe sport du Sénat par
exemple et par Michel Server ils ont
beaucoup parlé de sécurité
contestent pas de la nécessité de
sécuriser la Coupe du monde j'ai bien
entendu ce que vous avez dit sur les
risques de
cyberatta qui est sur l'inciter d'avoir
une cybersécurité tout cela ou le
partage moi j'ai beaucoup fréquenté de
matchs internationaux et nationaux
il est arrivé de parler avec les
policiers je peux vous dire qu'en
période de masse de rugby ils sont quand
même particulièrement décontracté et
plutôt des bonheurs donc il faut aussi
quand même rappeler ce qu'est le public
de rugby il y a pas plus beau public que
le public irlandais par exemple je peux
vous dire pour avoir été adjoint en
charge de l'espace public dans ma ville
de Biarritz alors là au domaine dommage
de Coupe d'Europe d'Europe Dieu sait si
les brasseurs étaient heureux mais Dieu
sait aussi si l'adjoueur en charge de
l'espace public était heureux et les
femmes panneaux d'aussi de signalétique
qui était retourné c'est aussi ça le
public de rugby et je tenais moi qui est
cher Pierre le dire avec force
alors on vous souhaite une belle
organisation on souhaite éventuellement
même si samedi le match à montrer qu'il
y avait encore du travail de beaux
résultats pour l'équipe d'un doigt
Dupont vous avez montré la dimension
mondiale
du rugby vous avez aussi montré je vous
en remercie la dimension moderne de
rugby mais je voudrais poser une
question un peu d'ordre politique le
rugby que vous avez décrit c'est un
public qui est en rugby qui devient
mondial c'est un rugby qui entre dans la
modernité c'est un rubis qui forme les
talents comme on l'avait répété qu'on
vous l'avez rappelé cadeau magnifique
centre de performance et tout ça c'est
important
mais il y a une autre réalité du rugby
qui a été évoqué par Jean-Jacques lossac
moins de licenciés moins de clubs dans
une terre comme la mienne le Pays Basque
ou le Béarn on assiste à des fusions de
club parce que dans le rugby des
sous-préfectures et des chefs de canto
qu'on est aujourd'hui une véritable
hémorragie du nombre de licenciés il y a
un vieillissement du public vous l'avez
dit vous-même vous l'avez avoué donc la
question a été posée mais je voudrais
vous titiller sur un point la question
vous avez été posée sur les retombées de
la Coupe du Monde rugby sur le rugby
amateur sur les clubs amateurs sur le
tissu sportif
sur ce la manière dont était construit
du rugby pour autant que regarde votre
vos cartes quand on regarde votre
déploiement et bon on observe une chose
c'est qu'il est profondément
métropolitain alors je sais que le
business le rugby et les métropoles ça
fonctionne mais est-ce que vous croyez
pas qu'à terme on est en train de scier
la branche sur lequel on est assis on
est en train de se priver de ce tissu de
formation que constituer les clubs
amateurs des chefs de canton et des
petites communes est-ce qu'on n'est pas
en train de créer un écart entre le
rugby moderne que vous avez pas fait
tellement présenté et la réalité du
rugby amateur et les choix que vous avez
fait dans cette Coupe du monde de rugby
n'écarte-t-elle pas la réalité la Coupe
du Monde de la réalité de ce rugby avec
Harris avec un terme à risque de briser
de vivacité de priver quasiment de de
son nouveau le rugby dont vous avez par
ailleurs des clés l'entrée dans
modernité je vous remercie oui merci
monsieur le Président moi je voudrais
juste faire une petite correction sur
la Coupe du monde de rugby c'est pas une
répétition ni même un brouillon des Jeux
Olympiques ça sera plutôt un exemple je
pense compte tenu des valeurs du du
rugby moi j'ai bien apprécié les
retombées géographiques avec la
répartition sur sur l'ensemble du
territoire il y a une deuxième
répartition géographique qui est plus
plus micro c'est celle qu'on sait que le
rugby max prison l'a dit c'est un
recrutement rural pour un sport d'élite
métropolitain dans les grandes villes
compte tenu de l'économie il y a quand
même une partie un peu du territoire qui
est moins concernée qu'on arrive moins à
pénétrer c'est celui des banlieues alors
certes il y a des beaux exemples comme
ce que fait le club de Massy par exemple
mais il y a un vrai travail est-ce qu'il
y a un travail spécifique qui va être
fait justement pour sensibiliser
des populations qui pas forcément très
acculturer par les valeurs du rugby et
ça je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'important
moi j'ai bien entendu
rassuré sur les problèmes de billetterie
et de revente parce que lorsqu'on vend
beaucoup de billets très à l'avance on
pouvait être inquiet sur le problème de
la revente des billets après il reste
deux choses pour moi c'est un risque et
un fléau savoir comment vous y êtes face
le risque c'est le sport et le rugby est
un sport on dit viril mais correct mais
qui malgré tout est quand même de plus
en plus violent et une des raisons
d'ailleurs un peu qui était analysée de
la désinfection un peu pour du rugby
c'est
lorsqu'on voit les les chocs et les
traumatismes qui peuvent être subis
quels sont le fait qu'on souhaite pas
que les enfants aillent pratiquer un
haut niveau ce sport et ce qui serait
dramatique pour pour cette coupe du
monde si c'est une réussite sportive
c'est qui est par exemple des
traumatismes qui marquent un peu avec
des joueurs qui gardent des séquelles et
je pense que là bénéfices qu'on pourrait
retirer de cet événement pourrait tomber
à l'eau deuxième chose c'est le fléau du
dopage qui maintenant touche tous les
sports et savoir s'il y a des choses
particulières qui vont être faites
comment ça va être traité pendant cette
coupe du monde voilà après pour rassurer
notre collègue billon Annick Billon et
sur les propos de Max Brisson le rugby
c'est un sport de voyou pratiqué par des
gentlemans qui savent les hommes savent
aussi acheter des places pour les pour
en offrir aux femmes pour qu'elles
puissent venir assister au match
dernière intervention rapide de Michel
sevain premier président rapidement ce
que tout à l'heure le président évoqué
les conditions de rupture de contrat de
l'ancien directeur général notamment sur
des motifs sur du harcèlement moral ma
seule question y a-t-il eu des plaintes
du personnel
ici on vous laisse répondre alors
peut-être d'abord moi je reviendrai sur
les deux mots que vous avez cités là la
célébration et les fraternités les
fraternité parce que je pense
qu'effectivement ce sont des mots très
très forts la célébration c'est la fête
et la fraternité c'est effectivement
c'est pas uniquement parce que c'est un
mot qui est inscrit à au fronton de nos
écoles et de nos établissements publics
mais c'est un mot très très fort très
riche et je crois que ça colle
parfaitement à ce que représente le
rugby et je pense que et c'est aussi ce
qu'on essaye de faire avec cette coupe
du monde c'est que finalement c'est ça
ça match parfaitement avec les les
valeurs du rugby et avec ce que peut
représenter une coupe du monde pour les
problématiques actuelles de la société
donc nous on a été amené à réfléchir
comme comme toute entreprise finalement
au sens à la mission à la raison d'être
d'une organisation comme celle de du
comité d'organisation d'une coupe du
monde comme le font maintenant les
entreprises et finalement on se dit
voilà on peut modestement parce que faut
pas non plus
survaloriser ce qu'on peut faire mais je
pense qu'on peut avec une coupe du monde
adressée en quelque sorte les
problématiques actuelles de la société
donc c'est ce plan RSE qu'on vous a
montré là avec des thèmes qui sont très
très structurants
l'économie durable et circulaire la
formation l'éducation l'emploi
l'environnement l'inclusion voilà c'est
des sujets qui sont des sujets actuels
de la société et si on résume ça avec ce
Clem ou ce un peu ce slogan ce qui va
nous guider maintenant jusqu'à jusqu'à
la Coupe du Monde un célébrons toutes
les paternités c'est ça parce que moi je
pense fondamentalement que le rugby est
moderne aujourd'hui et correspond
exactement aux problématiques actuelles
de la société une société qui est
fragmentée une société qui est
archipelisée segmentée où les gens se
referment sur eux-mêmes le rugby ça
attend du lien social le rugby avant
tout c'est le respect c'est le collectif
c'est l'engagement et ça c'est actuel et
c'est ce qu'on veut mettre en avant avec
cette coupe du monde et ça rejoint ce
que disait madame la sénatrice là qui
nous a quitté maintenant c'est aussi ça
je crois qui fait que aujourd'hui le
nombre de licenciés dans le rugby
augmente que les femmes une jeune fille
viennent au rugby parce qu'elles se
retrouvent dans les valeurs du rugby que
les familles viennent aujourd'hui
acheter des billets veulent aller voir
des matchs de rugby parce qu'on sait que
un match de rugby ça se passera bien et
c'est la fraternité la fraternité entre
les supporters la fraternité entre les
équipes dans un match de rugby l'équipe
perdante attend religieusement ou de
façon très respectueuse que l'équipe
gagnante et fait le tour des supporters
pour les saluer et font un
une raie d'honneur pour accueillir les
les perdants et les saluer lorsque les
Français avaient battu les Néo-Zélandais
à l'automne les All Blacks
respectueusement et très modestement ont
attendu que les Français aient fini leur
tour de leur tour du stade pour les
saluer c'est ça le rugby on trouve pas
ça dans les autres sports et moi j'ai
été j'ai été un ancien joueur de rugby
je suis encore maintenant éducateur dans
un petit club de rugby j'entraîne des
tout petits enfants qui ont 5 ans et 6
ans je suis très content de continuer à
faire ça parce que je suis un président
bénévole donc j'ai encore un peu de
temps pour faire ça et donc quand je
demande aux parents pourquoi vous amenez
vos enfants au rugby alors 50% c'est
parce que le grand-père le père Londres
la joue au rugby mais d'autres non c'est
pas pour cette raison là c'est tout
simplement pour les vertus éducatives du
rugby et ça c'est très fort je trouve
les parents vous disent ça aujourd'hui
le rugby ça a des valeurs éducatives et
je pense que c'est ça modestement qu'on
peut faire avec avec cette belle coupe
du monde et célébrer les fraternités
c'est tout ça qu'on va faire donc on est
on est très content que vous a derrière
à ce moto donc ça c'était l'aspect
positif alors pour revenir sur votre
question parce que vous y revenez sur la
sur la gouvernance bon effectivement on
reste un peu pudique sur ces sujets là
pour des raisons évidentes écoutez nous
on n'a pas de légitimité à à s'exprimer
sur les problèmes de gouvernance de la
de la Fédération française de rugby
peut-être que modestement moi avec mon
regard de de chef d'entreprise ou de
venant du monde de l'entreprise
peut-être que le mouvement sportif a
besoin effectivement de de d'évoluer au
niveau de sa gouvernance c'est un peu ce
qu'on ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui on
voit bien que par rapport au monde de
l'entreprise il y a sûrement encore un
des sujets sur lesquels il faut que le
le monde sportif évolue je pense que des
profils comme le mien des profils comme
comme Julien Colette sont peut-être
adaptés effectivement aux problématiques
actuelles de la gouvernance des du monde
du monde sportif
après
je pense qu'en miroir pour revenir au
problème de gouvernance qui sont
spécifiques au GIP vous comprendrez que
en miroir l'organisation ou la
gouvernance qu'on a mis actuellement en
place a pour but de répondre aux
dysfonctionnements qu'on a connu dans le
passé pour rester pudique si on a assez
au sujet proposé moi une gouvernance
collégiale collective transparente qui
vise à associer tout le monde c'est bien
pour répondre effectivement ce qui avait
peut-être dysfonctionné dans le passé
voilà donc pour rester encore une fois
pudique sur ces sujets là parce que j'ai
pas envie de revenir sur ces sujets qui
ont été douloureux pour pour les
événements pour pour l'événement et
surtout pour les collaborateurs parce
que qui ont souffert de cette période
difficile voilà voilà ce que je peux
vous dire de façon positive sur ces
sujets là et je crois qu'aujourd'hui on
a mis en place une gouvernance qui est
adaptée qui est moderne et qui est
adapté à la à la sophistication que
représente le pilotage d'un d'un grand
événement sportif comme celui-là parce
que moi venant encore une fois du monde
de l'entreprise je considère
qu'aujourd'hui un GIP un comité
d'organisation c'est une entreprise mais
une entreprise éphémère de par sa
définition mais qui est beaucoup plus
complexe qu'une entreprise parce que le
nombre de parties prenantes qu'il faut
fédérer autour du projet et très très
important entre les sponsors les villes
hautes les collectivités territoriales
l'état wordre rugby la Fédération
française de rugby voilà la mission de
notre collègue de notre comité
d'organisation c'est d'arriver à fédérer
tous monde là autour de l'événement et
c'est assez complexe et ça nécessite une
gouvernance et un management
probablement plus sophistiqué que ce
qu'on avait pu faire dans le passé ce
qu'on essaye de faire modestement
aujourd'hui
voilà après peut-être je laisserai
Julien répondre aux autres sujets
mais peut-être pour rebondir sur ce que
disait sénateur de la Corrèze on va
mettre à l'honneur le territoire
parisien puisque on participe à la
coproduction d'un film qui va bientôt
sortir et qui s'appelle port Lener qui
va montrer les vertus éducatifs du rugby
et le hasard fait qu'il se passe encore
voilà donc je fais un peu de publicité
mais je pense que c'est important parce
que ça mettra en valeur les valeurs
éducatives du rugby et ses vertus là ses
collègues j'interroge juste une seconde
il est sénateur des hautes claires
j'aimerais bien être sénateur de Corrèze
j'étais pris par son accent et des navré
je comprends mieux pourquoi vous vous
supporterez les deux équipes lors du
prochain match je comprends bien
concernant le modèle économique et la
sécurité le fait de choisir des stades
dans des métropoles premièrement si nous
avions fait un choix purement économique
nous n'aurions organisé les matchs qu'au
stade de France à Marseille alors c'est
vrai que les phases finales ne se
passent qu'au stade de France à
Marseille mais le but c'est de réunir
quand même au-delà de l'aspect
économique le maximum de fans et
aujourd'hui les deux stades qui
dépassent les 60 000 spectateurs
et qui sont modernes adaptés et
d'ailleurs le vélodrome encore plus que
le Stade de France de part sa rénovation
à sonde ce sont les stades que je viens
de citer pour le reste nous avons quand
même
choisi d'organiser des matchs dans 9
villes hautes dans 9 stade haute au
total dans des terres qui sont de rugby
et des terres qui ne sont pas de rugby
et dans des stades qui n'ont pas
forcément été modernisés récemment nous
aurions pu aussi ne choisir que les
stades issus de l'Euro 2016 ça n'a pas
été le cas nous avons choisi des stades
qui posent question qui ont posé
question à World rugby qui ont posé
question aux autorités sportives
nationales et internationales pour
permettre aux supporters de toute la
France de venir voir des matchs puisque
aujourd'hui 80% des Français vivent à
moins de deux heures de route d'un stade
donc c'était un choix important et qui
n'est pas qui qui a un choix de
compromis mais on doit faire des
compromis dans l'organisation d'un grand
événement entre le fait pouvoir
permettre au maximum de spectateurs de
regarder les matchs
à proximité de leur domicile ceci étant
nous n'avons pas écarté les territoires
encore une fois cette Coupe du Monde et
celle des territoires puisque les camps
de base sont répartis sur quasiment tout
le territoire alors il est vrai que le
grand est le grand oublié pour plein de
raisons est liée à la faiblesse de la
présence du rugby dans le Grand Est mais
la Bretagne ne l'est pas l'équipe
chilienne sera en grande base à
Perros-Guirec le club de le RC vannes
participent de manière active à
l'animation du territoire la Bretagne va
accueillir la Coupe du monde de rugby
militaire
il sera soutenu dans ce sens par les
majorité du rugby donc il y a un effort
très important qui est fait dans ce sens
et si cet effort d'ailleurs qui guide la
recherche d'un bénéfice non pas pour
assurer la rentabilité économique de
l'événement ça n'aurait aucun sens nous
sommes délégataires d'une mission
d'intérêt général une mission de service
public c'est pour
dégager
des enveloppes qui vont permettre de
financer des investissements en faveur
du développement du rugby sur tout le
territoire et l'équilibre que nous avons
cherché dans la revue budgétaire récente
c'est un équilibre entre assuré
l'excellence de l'organisation de
l'événement avec tout ce que ça implique
en terme de sécurité en termes de
qualité de de l'expérience spectateur et
donc
de conformité au standard internationaux
que vous citiez très justement monsieur
le sénateur parce qu'on a tendance dans
ce pays à chaque fois qu'on organise un
match un événement ou quoi que ce soit
d'autre à réinventer la poudre à ne pas
se comparer à ce que font les autres
alors que vous le disiez très justement
les Italiens dans le foot et dans le
rugby d'ailleurs sont de plus en plus
sont très performants et savent
parfaitement faire les choses et qu'on
n'a pas besoin de leur donner des leçons
mais c'est un point de vue personnel que
je me permets d'exprimer parce que je
pense qu'il est important
il est important et donc on est
aujourd'hui dans une stratégie très
forte de coopération avec les autres
acteurs nous ne ce n'est pas parce que
nous travaillons de manière très étroite
avec worldog be que nous sommes les
vallées des Anglais
je ne suis pas d'où vient cette rumeur
dans certains dans certaines parties du
rugby je pense que nous avons tout à
nous honorer de travailler de manière
très étroite avec tous les
professionnels du secteur qui sont qui
essaient d'organiser au mieux des grands
événements et de valoriser au mieux ce
sport partout dans le monde et les
bénéfices aussi de cette coupe du monde
vont profiter à d'autres nations de
rugby
voilà ce que je voulais dire sur cet
aspect là parce qu'il est important et
cet équilibre là il n'est pas facile à
trouver et il est c'est pour ça que nous
rendons régulièrement compte à nos
instances et dans notre conseil
d'administration siège de la FFR des
tailles c'est nos SF avec voix des
libératives mais siège beaucoup de
personnalités qualifiées avec vos
consultatives
dont les représentants des collectivités
locales et c'est important pour nous de
bénéficier de leur retour et nous sommes
aussi en lien permanent avec les clubs
amateurs sans doute insuffisamment mais
en tout cas c'est une réalité
que qu'il ne faut pas qu'il ne faut pas
cacher
au delà des
territoires ADN en rugby qui sont
effectivement on ne peut pas les oublier
ils sont au cœur de notre stratégie
effectivement il faut intéresser aussi
les jeunes des banlieues des grandes
villes à ce sport et de ce point de vue
là non seulement nous sommes en relation
avec des collectivités comme le
département de la Seine-Saint-Denis et
la ville de Saint-Denis nous allons
visiter encore ce soir pour mettre en
valeur leurs zones de célébration mais
nous allons aussi lancer un tournoi
national des quartiers qui dans les
quartiers des grandes villes par exemple
avec le soutien de la métropole de Lyon
va permettre d'organiser au pied des des
tours de constituer des équipes avec des
jeunes au pied des tours qui ne
connaissent pas le rugby et les équipes
gagnantes iront jouer à Marcoussis la
finale pendant la Coupe du Monde
c'est une petite pierre à l'édifice pas
suffisante mais aujourd'hui en équipe de
France il y a de plus en plus de jeunes
issus de ces territoires qui sont aussi
des des exemples et qu'on cherche à
valoriser à valoriser au mieux et de
plus en plus
je vais sans doute oublié des choses
pour ne pas me perdre concernant les
dispositifs de sécurité pour y revenir
effectivement
on cherche à encore une fois à coopérer
avec tous les acteurs encore une fois
les supporters de rugby ne sont pas
forcément organisés comme ceux de foot
c'est d'ailleurs peut-être un exemple à
suivre dans dans le rugby donc nous
travaillons plutôt avec les acteurs
institutionnalisés que sont les
fédérations on essaie aussi de
s'inspirer des pratiques qui sont mises
en place à l'occasion des championnats
et encore une fois on s'est organisé
aussi des matchs en France un des matchs
importants de Ligue 1 de Top 14 l'Euro
2016 c'est plutôt bien passé je crois
donc on a cette expérience là
analyser la menace de manière très fine
et puis à mobiliser des volontaires qui
viennent du rugby qui viennent de tous
les territoires de rugby 4500
volontaires vont
sur une réserve de 7000 d'ailleurs mais
4500 ont été sélectionnés vont être
mobilisés sur tous les territoires
et en complément les collectivités les
villes et les métropoles hautes vont
elles aussi mobiliser des volontaires
qui seront au contact direct avec les
spectateurs donc des passionnés de rugby
vont être en contact direct avec
d'autres passionnés de rugby pour les
aider à trouver leur chemin à aller vers
la bonne Fan Zone à trouver le bon accès
au stade etc etc
évidemment en relation étroite avec les
services de sécurité avec les forces de
sécurité intérieure
et de ce point de vue là nous avons
adapté les dispositifs effectivement de
sécurité en fonction de la taille et de
la jauge des stades nous mobilisons
jusqu'à 1000 agents de sécurité autour
du Stade de France pour 300 à la
Beaujoire
voilà écoutez j'espère d'un mot on n'a
pas répondu au sujet sécurité donc il y
avait sécurité des joueurs on a on a
pris deux décisions c'est ça a été
mentionné tout à l'heure c'est qu'on a
on a on a prolongé le la durée de la
compétition qui était de 45 jours
initialement on est passé maintenant à
51 jours tout simplement pour qui est
pour toutes les équipes ce qui était pas
le cas avant dans le format à 45 jours
on fait une période de 5 jours de repos
entre tous les matchs avant c'était pas
le cas il y avait des équipes qui
jouaient à moins de cinq jours donc
c'était pas bon pour la contrairement au
foot le rugby est un sport de de
d'engagement de combat collectif et il
faut récupérer entre deux matchs donc 5
jours c'est fait pour protéger la santé
la sécurité des joueurs et en plus on a
augmenté également le nombre de joueurs
participants avant c'était 31 maintenant
c'est passé à 33 donc il y a 33 joueurs
donc là aussi pour pour protéger la
santé des des joueurs et puis l'autre
sujet la dernière question que vous
posez c'est sur le dopage aussi
donc on travaille bien sûr avec World
rugby parce que c'est un sujet
fédération international et avec
l'Agence Française sur la lutte contre
le dopage bien sûr sur ces sujets là il
y aura des protocoles spécifiques et
puis on organisera pendant la
compétition ou c'est pas si c'est la
troisième ou la quatrième mais on
organisera une opération spécifique sur
sur le dopage sur la promotion à la
lutte contre le dopage pendant pendant
les événements pour sensibiliser à ce
sujet voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
là-dessus
[Musique]